Hello Vizzers, this is
the design challenge
starter if you've selected
the cost of protein
to make over. So let's go ahead
and check out the current Vizz, and
you can find it here underneath
this tab, cheapest protein in 2023.
You've got some background reading
that you can look into, and then
you'll have an Excel file with
the protein costs. Right now, the
existing viz is a simple bar chart
with some visualizations or some
icons above that. We're going to
recreate this and then do some
exploration, and then you'll have
a chance to redesign and submit.
So let's go ahead and jump into
the file. I've already pulled in
the Excel file into Tableau. And
as always, whenever you're doing
that, taking a look at what has
been provided and thinking through
the challenge to see if there's
anything you need to change.
So we have here the protein source,
the cost per 20 grams of protein,
the cost per package, and
that is in US dollars,
total protein per package,
and if it's vegetarian or
vegan, which could help us
with some filters to make
our chart more dynamic. So
let's go ahead and jump to our
first sheet and just recreate
that chart, that bar chart.
So we'll go ahead and
we'll do that cost per 20 grams
right here and the aggregation is
sum and then we'll do that
protein source on rows great do a
descending sort here and we'll add
in the cost onto label okay so we
see that cost and what I want to
do is let's go into the actual um
field on the data pane for the
cost for 20 grams and let's do um
we're going to do the properties we're
going to change the number format here
and we'll do currency make sure
that's a dollar two decimal
places that looks great
okay so now we just kind of
clean that up. I'm also going
to change this from standard
view to the entire view so
I can just fill that width.
So what I want to do is
just give you a little tip
to apply some of those design formatting
principles we talked
about in a previous AG.
I'm going to right click here on the
view and then I'm going to go into
format which will pull up that pane.
Again you can get that from this
drop down menu and I'm going to go
ahead and click on this line icon
right here and you'll see that it
says grid lines none now there are
some vertical grid lines so that's
a little confusing i get it what
what you'll have to do is select
and then deselect do you see how now
they've gone away not quite sure why
that is but um that's what i've what
i've done zero lines these are
those lines right there i'm going to
say none for that okay and for the
axis ruler I'm actually going to
say none for that so that was this
axis right down here and just by doing
that too and I have these labels
I'm going to right click this area
and just remove that header so just
by doing three steps I'm able to
really create a clean canvas to
begin working on and thinking about
design that's going to be part of
this challenge that's the majority of
this challenge you're really thinking
and being intentional about the
design choices that you're making
for this chart so you might consider
other headers or ways to focus your
audience's attention using design
so i'm going to go ahead and i'm
going to call this first sheet the
og the original data and i know that
the other one if i just flip this
i can you know, begin to replicate
a little bit of what it has. I don't
have the icons above it. Let me
just check out what we've got here.
So you can see here that we do
have that disending sort and I can
probably put on that canned
chicken, right? And then the salmon.
So, but for now, this is
basically what we've got. Don't
forget that you can also work
on some of the sizing issues to
make them skinnier or larger
all sorts of ways that you can
think about that but let's just
call that the OG for this first
remake and well I'll show you
a couple of other explorers
all right for this next sheet this
will be a wild card and this is
an opportunity for you to explore
I'm just going to put down a
wild card one you need to do at
least one exploration wild card but
you can do many I'm interested and
learning more about the protein
source and if it's vegan which
is has no dairy or vegetarian
and then I'm also kind of interested
in this grams total grams now
it's just creating something here
I you can actually even hold down
the measures and dimensions that
you're interested in and I'm
gonna go to show me to see what I
can see so based on this I've got
two falses here so this is not
telling me too much you see maybe
instead what I'm interested
in yes I'll put let me go back
so what I have is I got
protein on columns and vegan or
vegetarian and then on the text
i've got the total protein costs
and then what i selected was
the packed bubbles just because
i'm curious to see if there's
one that dominates and there is
that's that whey protein powder
but maybe i'll look at a couple
of these other chart types that
will also show part to whole
right so that's a little more
interesting to see how much
that dominates that um just kind
of curious what else i might
explore if it's helping me maybe
ask another question i do prefer
this one so i'm going to go ahead
and call this like i said the
wild card i think i deleted that
accidentally wild card 01 so i may
want to design that more or think
about that a little bit i might
put a filter in so i can only
show maybe the top three of that
maybe i'm only going to look at
vegan versus vegetarian so just
some potential areas of exploration
let's just do another wild card
because it's so much fun to
explore um data so then we have um
And then we have cost per package,
kind of interested in what that
might, and then protein per package.
So I've got my bar and kind
of looking at this heat map,
potentially I might even be able
to make another or to branch that
out to have some more depth
so cost per package and then
this is total protein which
clearly you could probably do some
summing 42 and I'm ready
we'll do a calculation to
figure out again this is per
20 grams so let me just put
that next to it so i'm
looking at grams versus total
so these are the same okay so
again these are just ways to
explore and hopefully um get you
more familiar about like what am
i trying to accomplish am i trying
to compare things i'm trying
to see part to whole do i want
to lift one of these ideas
out more than the others Do you
want to place a filter on that?
So I hope that you can
continue to explore.
Maybe you'll apply some
analytics to your chart.
I started to go down a rabbit hole by
creating a filter, if it was a yes or no,
if it's vegan, thinking I might
create a dashboard with just the
filter and parameter action but I sort
of stopped there and I'm not going
to demo that but that is something
if you want to take it further
and apply some of the other AGs
that you've learned but really your
next step should be this design
tab so you're going to take either
the OG that you've done or one of
the wild cards and then you're going
to be intentional about what you
want to convey and to use design
to create an awesome chart and I
can't wait to see. Happy visiting!